I hosted a show on, uh,
on Netflix called the ultimate Beastmaster and I got fired.
[Inaudible].
Great show. It's like American Ninja warrior,
like through like a Dragon's mouth, whatever.
They hired us to be the host of the team USA. And they told me, they're like,
look, you're a comedian. Okay. All for white women. You're a comedian.
Make fun of the other countries.
I got fired immediately because people were tweet and going nuts.
But I had one joke that people going off about it's like you called up. Okay.
So the wa if you fell into the water, they called it the beast blood.
So the Chinese team was going,
and one of these competitors fell off it and his name was Ben Fong,
and he fell off into the water, but I didn't call it the beast blood. I go,
that goes, Ben Fung into the duck sauce.
[Inaudible].